after disappearing from hollywood
casting list brendan fraser has
experienced something of a career
revival of late he's part of the hbo max
tv show doom patrol and he'll be in the
upcoming killers of the flower moon from
martin scorsese but the star is fondly
recalled by many because of the part he
played in movie going memories during
the 1990s and 2000s like blast from the
past crash and encino man given that
it's natural that his newly reclaimed
status as a working actor is giving
media and fans the opportunity to ask
about old projects they loved one of
those projects is the mummy which hit
theaters way back in 1999 and spawned
sequels and animated series spin-off
series and the 2017 reboot flop starring
tom cruise
that reboot was supposed to jump start
the dark universe franchise but its
failure to ignite much interest made
universal pictures take a long hard look
at its strategy and focus on
individualized standalone features
instead despite that 2017 failure there
are a lot of people out there with fond
memories of the 1999 original it did
bring that sort of indiana jones vibe to
a new generation of fans in a sense
given this it's hardly a surprise that
fraser was asked about returning to the
mummy at fan expo canada in 2019 a fan
asked frasier if there were any new the
mummy movies on the horizon he responded
for me do you want one naturally this
response received plenty of cheers from
people in the audience so he said did
you hear that universal after feigning
ignorance about the 2017 reboot he
acknowledged he would be on board for a
new version absolutely he told the crowd
but there seems to be a bit of a caveat
fraser said just gotta say i know how
hard it is to make that movie i try to
do it three times and the essential
ingredient is fun you gotta remember to
have fun so if there's a fun way to
approach it again i'm all in he also
praised his co-star in the first two
movies he commented i mean come on it's
rachel vice she's lovely she got stuck
with all the exposition in that show
which is good that means all the talking
i was just the guy like hurry up let's
go come on that thing is going to go
bang it worked out of course just
because he's up for another the mummy
installment doesn't mean the film's
gonna happen however there was a time
when a fourth movie in the mummy
franchise was in the works the brennan
frasier starring the mummy trilogy of
films was a classic case of diminishing
returns while the original is remembered
as a cult classic the sequel doesn't
have quite the same cultural cache and
the mummy tomb of the dragon emperor
enjoys even less fan enthusiasm that's
the one with the yetis plural presumably
besides the yetis again plural the film
recast rachel vice with maria bello
which ended up not working out as
expected nothing against maria bello but
the actor change was just another
jarring blow to the weakest entry in the
series according to simon brew film
stories the cast of tomb of the dragon
emperor were signed up for several more
potential films in the series with the
next installment having already been
hashed out the fourth movie would follow
in the footsteps of the third by
switching up the location of the action
this time to latin america the mummy
rise of the aztec would have presumably
followed in similar footsteps as the
previous films but obviously with an
aztec mummy instead of immotep or the
dragon emperor one of the most
intriguing bits of information about the
cancelled fourth film is that antonio
banderas was apparently slated to play
the mummified villain rise of the aztec
was even lightly set up at the end of
tomb of the dragon emperor with the
character jonathan announcing that he's
on his way to peru will we ever get to
see the fourth entry in the mummy
franchise if the internet gets its way
it'll be a yes with frasier's popularity
swinging back up again fans on social
media are trying to make it happen as
one tweeted all this brendan fraser
momentum will surely lead to a mummy
sequel and i'm here for it
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
brendan fraser coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one